okay so how many people are here because
they love hockey how many people here
because they're interested in web
scraping how many people are here
because they wanted to know how I'm
related to Joel hopefully all of your
interests will be answered in this talk
so this sylla's and exercise that I
undertook um because I was interested in
learning a little bit more about web
scraping so I think when you're starting
off with that news from a project like
that it's important to pick a topic that
you have a lot of interesting that
usually helps you make it all the way
through I happen to be a big hockey fan
so i decided i was going to look at
hockey data and specifically i was going
to look at hockey penalty data if you're
not familiar with hockey penalties
they're kind of like penalties in in
football there when you break the rules
and you get caught the big difference is
that instead of being penalized in yards
you're being penalized in that you have
to go sit off the ice and your team has
to play with one less person so here i'm
going to say a look at how do penalties
affect the outcome of the game one of
the most famous types of penalties in
hockey is the fighting penalty these
this is actually a seattle thunderbirds
hockey game they're their junior hockey
team here which is unfortunately all we
can get right now um but I if you go to
junior game which are still really fun
that's like something you might see um
so Alice I said a lot of this already um
I am Joel sister so if that's all you're
interested in I you don't have to stay
for the rest of the talk of but most
importantly which was not part of my
introduction is that I am a big
philadelphia flyers fan so I watch a lot
of hockey and I read a lot about hockey
um and so I'm interested in in different
aspects
hockey and one one of the most fun parts
is definitely the penalties some hockey
101 in case you don't know anything
about the game there's a rink there's
five skaters per side so and plus a
goalie so regular play is five on five
but when a player gets a penalty so they
break the rules they have to go sit in
the penalty box ah they either sit in
the penalty box for about two minutes or
they say in the penalty box for five
minutes and so for that whole time
usually their team is playing down a
player so you would think that that
would definitely have a negative impact
on their team's performance in the game
and there's a wide variety of of players
in hockey there's the real skill guys
who score all the goals make all the
fancy moves and then they go all the way
down to the enforcers and those are the
guys who are gonna get in fights try to
mess with the other teams head and so so
if they're also could be a factor of
who's getting the penalty you know and
and as far as what outcome it might have
so obviously hockey penalties put your
team at disadvantage you playing with
fewer players but can they ever help you
in the game um hockey fights which I'm
not going to talk about as much um they
have a big entertainment value in the
game everyone loves hockey fights you
know if you've seen slap shot have you
seen the movie goon you know it's all
about fighting but uh but those aren't
the other those aren't the only kinds of
penalties um so I was inspired for this
particular talk um by a zac rinaldo who
is the enforcer type on the Philadelphia
Flyers so last January Flyers were
playing the Penguins and zac rinaldo
slams one of the Penguins players into
the boards
let's see if it will load so it happens
right at the top right corner right now
and then they replay it they'll replay
it again in slow motion so that is a
particularly dirty type of penalty um
called boarding where you're slamming a
guy into the boards when he has no idea
you're coming at him so he can't make
any defensive moves to keep himself from
being injured um sec Ronaldo has a has a
reputation for doing these sorts of
things um and he thought he got a
penalty and he got ejected from the game
so he was no longer in the game but
could he still have had an effect on the
game after the game in his media
interview he said yeah I changed the
whole game man who knows what would have
happened what it would have what with
the game have been like if I didn't do
that the league did not agree with him
and they suspended him 880 so I
approached Zach Ronaldo's question that
you posed to me as to look at penalty
penalty data and seeing if it has a
positive effect on the outcome of the
game for the team who gets the penalty
um so these were the sort of main steps
that I I went through to to do my
projects first I had to design the
experiment then I needed to scrape pars
data I needed to clean and combine data
and then I needed to analyze all that
data together um so to design the
experiment I was using my brain this is
my own personal brain is not a module in
Python called brain um and then to
scrape and parse the data
I use requests I initially set out to
use beautiful soup I'll get at why that
did not work and then I also use regular
expressions in HTML parser and then for
the analysis i use panas in stats models
so first what is the question that you
want to answer when you're designing
your experiment I was interested in how
the hockey penalties affect the outcome
of the game okay that's a good question
so what yeah well I need oh I'm gonna
need some penalty data some game data
some player data what data is available
oh there's hockey game player data
available and Honda sports websites so I
just have to figure out which one's work
best for me oh then is there some
specific types of data i was interested
in for the penalty you know which team
will player what type of penalty is it
the game information so who's playing
what's the state of the game when the
penalty happens you know is the team
that's taking the penalty you aren't
they uh down are they head are they tied
and then a little bit about player
information of what type of player got
the penalty like i said that there's
there's quite a range which we can a
real skill guy who is valued on the ice
versus the enforcer guy who just likes
to get in fights um so oh and i want to
about getting some game data I thought
that there were two questions I should
answer about um where I should pick it
from a one is how easy is it to automate
from moving from page to page and then
the second is how easy is it to get the
information I want out of the source
code so for the further play-by-play
game d'ye I got that from NHL com they
have this a string that's constant for
all their games followed by a season
indicator followed by another constant P
L stands for
play-by-play data and 02 indicates
regular season and then there is a
four-digit code that corresponds to the
game in the season so there's 1230 games
in the season so each one gets a number
um I I got 10 10 seasons worth of NHL
regular season games over the course of
these 10 years there's a switch in how
NHL com was presenting their
play-by-play data so for the first five
years it's this part on the left and it
basically just looks like a text block
in in a website on the on the right or
the later seasons and it's a little bit
more complicated there's obviously some
tables embedded in there but I can get
the same information from both from both
formats you know I'm looking at what was
the time of the penalty what was the
penalty who got it and was the score
when it happened so the earlier seasons
that look like a block of text in the
HTML they actually were a block of text
in the HTML so basically it's just
parsing a text file to get the
information out of there and then for
the for the later seasons again it was
some embedded tables in this HTML file
so to get all the games i can just loop
through all the seasons and then loop
through all the games and then I have
all the content for ten seasons worth of
NHL games it was pretty simple one thing
to think about is what should what
should we do with the results should we
pars it on the fly or should download it
and store it for performance and just so
that you're can test your code multiple
times or tweak your code it makes sense
to download it and store it from a
practical personal perspective we are
philadelphia flyers fans so we watch all
of our games on NHL com and I was
downloading you know twelve thousand
twelve thousand games from nhl.com I
wanted to sort of make it as unlikely as
possible that they might block our IP
address because I would get in a lot of
trouble if we couldn't watch our hockey
games at home um so uh to to get the
penalties they made it really easy for
me it just says penalty in the in the
line right up here so I just needed to
extract all the lines that said penalty
and then strip out the information that
I was interested in uh four goals again
it says goal in it so that makes it
really easy to identify the line that
I'm interested in and figure out um
figure out a and extract out the
information I need four goals it was a
little bit more difficult because there
are also some lines that said boli and I
didn't want those lines I just wanna go
on set said go for the for the later
seasons I try to use beautiful soup
especially in the in the early parts of
these of this format whoever was making
these play by plays um was not a super
HTML star and um the the sites are
terribly formatted and beautiful soup
would not recognize them as um as HTML I
tried a few different HTML parser Xin
beautiful soup and it was not finding
anything for me I did identify a little
bit of the source of that problem with
that a lot of this a lot of the games in
the first few seasons of this floor mat
we're coated with the care
just set utf-16 which beautiful soup
will not read at all so once i changed
it to utf-8 utf-8 at least it would read
them but it still couldn't parse them um
and then so here it was a little bit
more complicated for these files and
they are a lot bigger because of their
more complicated so here I had to look
for a line that said he and L and then
get the information that I wanted from
the lines above it and blow it which
made it a little bit more complicated
it's ok and then again same four goals
the goal the line that says goal doesn't
actually have any information i'm
interested in it so i had to figure out
a pattern where the information about
the goal really was and that consisted
of lines that had of the word ft period
indicating how far away the shot was
made from and then a parenthesis which
indicated that somebody had just scored
a goal and was getting a one or two for
that game and so for every penalty
regardless if it was from the early
format or the later format i recorded
the team the player the period the time
the powerplay links and the score at the
time of the game the regulation score
the final score the season and the game
so i had all the same information um i
also wanted to get some player data
because i wanted to be able to account
for you know is this the real skill guy
is this an enforcer guy i got this
information from espn.com they they have
an indicator for the season again and
then you can just iterate through their
pages in intervals of 40 oh so that's
what i did there there a their data is
it looks like a garbled mess but um it's
actually highly structured
oh so if I had still been one thing to
use beautiful soup at this point I
probably could have gotten the
information from here too to get all the
seasons of stats again loop through the
seasons loop through the accounts in
interval 240 and then just keep adding
that on to the same file so this is what
like the table looks like you can see
it's very well structured and there's
the same information for every player so
that kind of makes me think um maybe a
regular expression would be would be
good for this to get extract out the
information i so i made this regular
expression and then it looks a lot more
complicated than it is but I basically
just copied out a whole unit that I knew
I wanted to repeat for everybody and
changed all the variable parts um there
were some some interesting finds like if
you are a wing you had RW but if your
Center you had just see but I didn't
realize that there was a space
afterwards that was really important um
so first I was only getting stats for
for wingers and I was like what's going
on and then I realized there was this
extra space I down there and then I can
use HTML parser to extract out all the
texts from from the regular expressions
um using two different data sources led
to some confusions so when I went to
combine the data oh so NHL gave them the
players by their number their last name
in their team and then the ESPN Stats
gave their players by first name last
name and all the teams that they played
for during the season this is so
wouldn't be a problem to match them all
up if there was only one guy on the team
with with that last name but this is the
famous computer science brother problem
Oh
where there's a lot of sets of brothers
or not actual brothers with just people
with the same last name who are on the
same team until I had to come up with a
strategy to make sure I was matching up
the right stats with the right guy given
that I had two completely different sets
of data teams teams can change names um
so like the Anaheim Ducks it used to be
called the mighty ducks of anaheim and
then they became the Anaheim Ducks
Arizona coyotes used to be called the
winnipeg jets and for that they were of
phoenix coyotes and now there are the
Arizona coyotes so we have to be able to
take into account that um that the team
names might not always be the same and
but we want the code to work for for all
the teams and all the seasons and then
the penalty data was interesting it's
kind of interesting to look at the
evolution of what they called penalties
over the course of these ten years so
there was like board checking and then
boarding and then high stick and high
sticking so there were in the data set
there were 118 distinct names of
penalties but many of these correspond
to the same exact penalty so I
standardized the names of these
penalties and categorize them into six
penalty types so physical foul that's
what I'm calling on one of these dirty
penalties where your ear out to injure
someone so like me boarding um
head-butting uh something like that but
some of these other penalty categories
are a little bit it can be accidental or
they could eat accidental and again
going back to the penalty that was the
inspiration for my talk it was the
physical fouls so that's pretty much
what I but I focus on for the
analysis portion of the talk um I
measured the outcome in two ways so
first was I look for a positive change
in the game following the penalty so
that's where the final state of the game
is better than the state of the game
when the team took the penalty so like
if they're tied when the penalty happens
but then they win or if they're losing
and then they tie or when those would be
positive changes and then the second one
I looked at was next goal which is that
if the team that gets the penalty also
scores the next goal so these two
different outcomes are kind of kind of
getting at you know if there is an
effect is it very localized to around
the penalty or is it systemic to the
whole rest of the game so for outcome
one which was again was positive change
I analyzed all individual 119,000
penalties from these ten regular-season
games or these ten seasons
regular-season games so again these are
the types of data that I collected or
that I had for each um for each penalty
some information that I didn't talk
about when I was talking about
extracting from the penalty files
where's home team so this is an
indicator for was the team that got the
penalty the home team or not the wind
percentage of the team that took the
penalty and the wind percentage of their
opponents and then these last two are
related to the particular player which
is average time on ice for game and
average number of penalty minutes per
game so this is just sort of a
description of these um these five types
I didn't include bench because I'm only
looking at individual data and
penalties are like taken by the team so
there's no of those individual stats to
include so again this is a stick
infractions physical files penalty shots
of physical altercations are fighting
and then delay of game on these are
descriptions of how their associated we
could take out our calculators and look
at that or we can do a logistic
regression so I use logistic regression
to build a model that predict the
outcome of the game based on different
features that i was looking at um so
again this log ratio of the outcome
happening and then I would include
different features this is based on a
post on why head calm so I was going to
investigate Zach Ronaldo's claim that he
made a positive change so without any
other covariance of game or penalty
features i looked at physical fouls and
found that there is about a 13 point
eight percent increased chance of
getting a positive change in the game if
your penalty if your team takes a
physical foul and this is I mean this is
crazy right you're out to like you're
out to injure someone and then you get
kicked out of the game and then it helps
your team it's very weird um but so then
I was like well I gotta control for all
these other factors in the game that I
know are going to UM be involved but
even when I control for the team and
opponent's strengths it's still you know
13.5 percent increase so we talked a
little bit about the player effect so
these are those two stats that I was
talking about before of how I measured
um player affect the time on ice is on
the y and penalties in penalties per
game is on the x the blue line is the x
equals wide line you can see those four
guys who spent more time in the penalty
box on average then on the ice per game
most three of the four of those were
from the two earliest seasons which was
before the 2004-2005 walk out when they
made a lot of rule changes and penalty
minutes started going down um and then
the other one I like on here is this guy
out here um this guy is an enforcer but
this was his first season in the NHL um
and he got brought up on a team that
already had an enforcer so he had to
play a lot of minutes because he
couldn't read that guy who was just
getting into fights but he is still a
gritty dirty player so he got a lot of
time two minutes so that's how he ended
up out there um but where are those
different players that are different
types of players I was talking about
before fall out on this chart lady byng
trophy is it is a trophy for a good
sportsmanship so those are guys who
don't get a lot of penalties so you can
see and the blue they're very close to
zero penalty minutes per game in the red
and purple those are the real skill guys
either the skill defenseman or the
skilled forwards and there on the ice a
lot so they might happen to get some of
these accidental penalties more but they
but they don't get a lot of penalties
and then down in green I've highlighted
a few of the enforcer types and these
guys don't play a lot and they also
spend a lot of time in the penalty box
all right so you kind of think about
would it matter
who is getting the penalty you know
we're always used to the enforcement
getting a penalty so we're kind of over
that so that's not going to affect us
whereas it's one of these skilled guys
gets it then you know maybe that will
really fire up the team of our captain's
going out there and getting penalties
for us when I included these two stats
into the model neither of them was I was
significant so neither of them seems to
have a significant effect on how
physical fouls affects the outcome of
the game um and the odds ratio again was
thus about 13% increased chance of
having this positive change even that
your team has a physical foul so the
second one I looked at was next goal and
that's a there was only one hundred two
thousand penalties because not all the
penalties had a goal scored after them
but then the the outcome was was really
pretty much the same um I still saw this
this a positive positive effect on
scoring the next goal after having a
physical foul so when is it good to be
bad um I guess it's good to be bad if
you have a physical foul penalty um
that's kind of a weird thing to say
because you're actually going out and
trying to injure somebody um so that it
doesn't seem like it should be it should
be good to be bad in that situation when
you have a similar records year
opponents so having an opponent with a
really good record definite was was bad
for both of these positive change
outcomes and uh and having a really good
record yourself was good so the team
effect clearly clearly is there but if
you but if you have about the same
record then that can be balanced out
when you're the home team this makes a
lot of sense because the crowd really
gets into it
and then and then when you're down or
tied early in the game so the effects
are stronger in the first period if
these penalties happen in the first
period versus later in the game that
makes sense there's there's less time
for you to actually um come back or win
the game so it's zac rinaldo changed the
effect so that grand also did get a
physical foul so that's plus one for
that Ronaldo the Flyers were much worse
than the Penguins at this point in the
season so that's one against efrain Aldo
Philly was the home team so plus 14
ronaldo when you're down or tied early
in the game a Philly was actually a head
at the time of this penalty so um so I
guess yes I I don't know he particularly
changed the game he's no longer
Philadelphia Flyers so maybe that's how
the Flyers management thought of the
whole situation um yeah